talk to me about uh big tech censorship
i know you've spent a lot of time
obviously in silicon valley uh uh
talking with both employees people who
start businesses like this and uh
it feels like you know the tide has
turned a little bit and and maybe the
the way that the average citizen thinks
about these platforms is not the same as
it was 10 years ago when they were you
know considered startups and the
darlings of
of business coverage what's the thoughts
there in terms of how do we fix some of
these problems they're not startups
anymore they are uh they are so big that
i think they need to be regulated as
public utilities you know and everybody
wants to freak out actually very few
people freak out but it's academic it's
the libertarian economic theorist they
freak out they're like blake you could
not regulate facebook right facebook's a
private company you can't regulate it
and i say like facebook may be nominally
private although functionally right it's
so uh entwined with the biden white
house the gen saki just tells facebook
what to take down because that's cobit
misinformation we can't be spreading
that disinformation
so facebook's not even that private but
even if you can see that it's private
it's still so big and so powerful that i
think you've got to take a look at it
and recognize
it's not a local bakery it's not a small
or medium business this is a global
communications utility with 100 actually
billions of people right probably over a
billion people on facebook at this point
um and when you let a handful of
multinational corporations i think it's
like the new town square right they
control the flow of information in a
society uh
in a real sense when you let them just
do whatever they want around election
time i really worry that you can't get a
free and fair election so i think it's
crazy that they ripped off president
trump facebook and twittered it um they
censored marjorie taylor green i don't
care if you love her or hate her
politics
she's still an elected official and and
deserves that platform uh and shouldn't
be silenced just because her views are
to the right of you know people at
facebook or whatever and so i think
you've got to regulate these companies
as common carriers just like the phone
company right the phone company can't
listen to you and me and say oh they're
talking about bitcoin that makes us
uncomfortable let's disconnect them
they'd probably love to do that but
they're not allowed to do that and so
why on earth shouldn't we treat facebook
and twitter the same way yeah one of the
things that's uh that's fascinating to
me is i think it was naval uh maybe or
somebody tweeted and was like if you can
silence the king you are the king uh
in terms of this thought process of like
uh at what point does power kind of
coalesce uh in a society and it used to
be very much in yeah the monarch days at
the king or queen level uh in other uh
types of government organizations
there's authoritarian leaders and and
all this stuff but now there is uh very
much a deep you know collection of power
at many of these platforms and so uh if
we think about facebook and twitter i
think that's gotten a lot of the
conversation in america given its uh
interaction with politics uh but if we
go and we look at something like tick
tock i think that that now is becoming a
bigger conversation uh in this you know
i don't know maybe it's like a passive
competition a
battle whatever you want to call it with
china uh and the use of ai and
algorithms and this like soft power how
do you think about something like a tick
tock obviously being consumed very
heavily now the most popular website in
the entire world uh but maybe doesn't
align necessarily with some of the uh
the american way of either thinking or
trying to actually roll out these
technologies
yeah i think i think we should ban tick
tock um the trump administration was
close and didn't didn't quite get it
done but i think we probably should just
because it it i think all that data goes
back to the ccp are functionally it's
accessible to them and it's really crazy
like the scale at which we are allowing
our young people teenagers and even
preteens to um
to just chronicle their lives to upload
their their faces and their behaviors
and their their backgrounds uh
to the chinese communist party via tick
tock
which they say you know has an american
subsidiary so don't worry about it but
no actually it's a chinese company um i
think tick tock is probably unhealthy in
other ways you know but if we're a
swedish company uh i'd have
way fewer concerns
what's the thought process so like let's
say uh
everyone uploads all this information
like what's the concern with them having
it is it more so that uh they build a
database and they're able to exploit it
in some way is it the programming of
children's minds like just talk to me a
little bit more in terms a little bit
the louder more the former like i don't
know i'll be honest i don't know exactly
what uh what china is doing with this
data um
but i but i bet it's not good and to me
it seems kind of like an own goal uh to
be giving it to them and again the scale
is just i think orders of magnitude more
um than what most people think uh so so
i don't know but it just it doesn't it
doesn't seem good like china is the
geopolitical rival um
i you know we're already in a cold war
with china and let's pray that it you
know we sort of win that so that it
never becomes a hot war in you know 10
20 30 years but they're the geopolitical
rivals so to take a whole generations uh
i mean literally faces expressions
behaviors voices and give that over
to the chinese communist party that
seems a little foolhardy to me at least
we should be investigating it uh and
really wondering like hey let's let's
quantify and actually describe like
what's the problem here what's the
solution but you sense that the biden
administration is just uh laissez-faire
they don't care at all hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time